Profª. Tamar Gendler: Hoje eu vou
rentabilizar o dinheiro de vocês,
no sentido de que alguns podem
utilizar esta aula como uma prova
para ver se gostariam de ter uma outra
aula de filosofia no futuro.
E embora muito do que
esteja sendo visto aqui
seja típico de uma aula de filosofia,
uma das coisas que não fazemos
em grande quantidade
é uma leitura mais detalhada das
longas passagens dos textos.
O que eu quero fazer hoje é analisar
como um grupo... isso significa
que eu falo e vocês escutam,
portanto não é bem um grupo.
Analisar uma parte do Ética de
Aristóteles – o Livro II, Capítulo 4
–,
com vocês todos aí, sorrindo para mim,
para tentar situar as 2 respostas
que lemos para hoje e que
exemplificam o tema do curso.
Então basicamente o
primeiro 4º da aula
será analisar esta
passagem de Aristóteles.
Vou expor o texto e conversar
com vocês a partir dele.
E eu quero apresentar como
é que os 2 artigos
lidos para hoje captam partes
muito específicas
e muito precisas do texto aristotélico.
Como eu disse, vamos
observar atentamente
algo no livro que estamos lendo de
Aristóteles: Ética a Nicômaco.
Em especial, já ouvimos
por várias vezes
a afirmação de Aristóteles de
que as virtudes de caráter
são adquiridas a partir
da habituação.
Que, assim como uma pessoa se torna
um harpista tocando harpa,
também se torna justo agindo
como alguém justo,
corajoso agindo como alguém corajoso.
Mas o próprio Aristóteles percebe que
isso não pode ser a história
completa e ele começa a sua
discussão no Livro II, Capítulo 4,
que já lemos 2 vezes nesta classe...
a 1ª há algumas semanas e
voltamos a ler para terça-feira.
Aristóteles observa que:
"Alguém poderia perguntar que
entendemos nós ao declarar que
devemos tornar-nos justos
praticando atos justos
e temperantes praticando
atos temperantes.
Porque, se um homem
pratica tais atos,
é que já possui essas virtudes."
Aristóteles quer corrigir
uma possível
má-interpretação do que ele
alega.
Em particular, ele quer
ressaltar que embora isso
seja uma condição necessária,
para ser justo e temperante,
que alguém pratique atos
justos e temperantes,
não se trata de uma
condição suficiente.
Ou seja, apesar de ser um requisito
para ser justo e temperante
que você aja da forma que a pessoa
justa ou temperante age,
isso não é o bastante.
Você precisa de algumas
outras coisas além disso.
E o que estamos fazendo hoje é refinar
o entendimento do que já sabemos.
Nós já sabíamos pelas leituras
e pelas aulas anteriores
que Aristóteles diz: para ser
justo você tem de agir
como o justo age e se habituar
a esse tipo de ação.
E agora ele vai apresentar
algumas condições adicionais
sobre a justiça, temperança
e outras virtudes.
Ele diz: para que "os atos que
estão de acordo com as virtudes
tenham determinado caráter,
não se segue que sejam praticados de
maneira justa ou temperante;
também é mister que o
agente se encontre
em determinada condição
ao praticá-los".
O que Aristóteles quer dizer com isso?
O que ele quer dizer com: para um
ato ser feito com justiça,
não basta, não é suficiente,
que ele seja praticado de maneira justa?
Além disso, o agente tem de estar
em determinada condição
ao praticá-lo.
Vamos supor que eu aja de
forma temperante
simplesmente porque os
recursos necessários
para que eu aja de forma
intempestiva não estão
disponíveis.
Vamos supor que a razão pela
qual eu deixe de beber
o leite achocolatado que normalmente
está na minha geladeira é
porque não há leite achocolatado na
minha geladeira para eu beber.
Vamos supor que a razão pela qual
eu deixe de ir a uma festa
no sábado à noite é porque não há
festas disponíveis para eu ir.
Nesse caso, segundo Aristóteles,
eu agi como uma pessoa
temperante agiria.
Mas eu não fiz isso como resultado de
estar em determinada condição.
Ou eu poderia, com a
intenção de dar um objeto
para alguém a quem não o pertence,
devolvê-lo de forma equivoca
ao seu dono legítimo.
Se eu fizer isso, eu devolvo o
objeto ao dono legítimo.
Eu ajo como a pessoa justa agiria.
Mas eu não fiz isso pelo
motivo correto.
Aristóteles quer dizer que se
você é temperante
só porque não tem a chance de
agir de forma intempestiva,
mas que se você tivesse
a chance agiria;
e que você agir como a
pessoa justa agiria
não porque tem o objetivo de ser justo,
mas porque dispõe de informações
erradas, o seu ato não conta
como uma instância da virtude
que interessa a ele.
Em especial, Aristóteles diz que é
preciso satisfazer 3 condições
para o seu ato justo contar
como um ato virtuosamente justo
ou o seu ato temperante
contar como um ato
temperante... e assim por
diante.
1º: É preciso praticar o ato
sabendo que você está
fazendo algo virtuoso.
2º: É preciso decidir praticar o ato
exatamente porque ele é virtuoso.
3º: É preciso fazer isso a
partir do que ele chama
de um "estado firme e imutável".
Portanto, a 1ª condição é
estar numa situação
em que você saiba qual
ato é o virtuoso.
A 2ª é optar por esse ato
porque ele é o virtuoso.
A 3ª é que a sua escolha
não seja algo pontual
ao que acontece nesta situação,
mas tampouco em outras.
E sim que a sua escolha seja expressiva,
seja indicativa, decorrente de
um estado de caráter
que você possui e que
persiste ao longo do tempo.
Eu vou dar alguns exemplos
disso num minuto.
Aristóteles resume afirmando que
"as ações são chamadas justas e
temperantes quando são tais
como as que praticaria o homem
justo ou temperante",
onde a pessoa justa não é aquela
que pratica as ações,
"e sim o que as pratica
tal como o fazem os justos
e temperantes".
Portanto, essa questão
nos deixa com esta:
Como uma pessoa justa, temperante,
corajosa ou virtuosa pratica esses atos?
Vamos analisar isso com o
exemplo da coragem...
Como podemos satisfazer as 3
condições aristotélicas?
A 1ª condição é praticar a ação
com conhecimento de causa.
Então vamos supor que eu
esteja no campo de batalha
e sei que existem 2 grupos de
soldados: os corajosos e os covardes.
E eu tenho a certeza absoluta
de que não me interessa em nada
arriscar a minha vida.
Portanto, eu tomo a decisão que
o meu plano será fazer
o que os covardes fizerem.
E me posiciono no meio de
um grupo de pessoas
a quem eu considero soldados covardes
e eu faço o que eles estiverem fazendo.
Se eu perceber que, por um lapso,
escolhi imitar o grupo de
soldados corajosos,
em vez do grupo de soldados covardes,
eu vou executar um comportamento
igual ao comportamento da
pessoa corajosa,
mas eu não da forma que a
pessoa corajosa faria.
Eu pensei que imitava os covardes,
mas porque eu me enganei sobre
quem eram os corajosos
e quem eram os covardes,
equivocadamente eu imitei uma ação
que acabou por ser corajosa.
Aristóteles diz: Nenhum crédito.
Nenhum crédito para a ação virtuosa.
O 2º requisito é que, além de saber
qual é a ação virtuosa e
qual é a não-virtuosa,
eu tenho de decidir praticar a
ação porque ela é virtuosa.
Então vamos supor uma
situação similar.
Eu estou no campo de batalha.
Eu sei qual é o grupo de covardes e
qual é o grupo de corajosos
e decido, porque eu quero ter
uma boa reputação,
que eu vou fazer o que os
soldados corajosos fizerem.
Portanto, eu estou executando de forma
consciente um ato corajoso,
mas não porque ele é corajoso,
mas porque fazendo isso eu vou
expressar uma virtude,
porque fazendo isso eu vou levar a bom
termo esta condição ideal
enfatizada por
Aristóteles como
relevante.
Eu estou fazendo isso porque me
interessa receber uma medalha.
Eu estou fazendo isso porque me interessa
conseguir uma boa reputação.
Aristóteles diz que mesmo se
eu fizer a coisa certa,
mesmo se eu fizer a coisa certa
com conhecimento de causa,
se eu fizer isso com a motivação
errada em mente... Nenhum crédito.
Em 3º lugar, Aristóteles diz que,
para uma ação contar como uma
expressão de virtude,
eu não só tenho de praticá-la
com conhecimento de causa
e pelo motivo certo,
como praticá-la de tal
forma que ela expresse
um traço caracterológico meu que se
estende ao longo do tempo.
Então vamos supor que desta vez eu
decida agir de forma corajosa
pelo bem de ser corajoso,
embora geralmente eu aja
de forma covarde.
Aristóteles diz
que mesmo se eu fizer isso com
conhecimento de causa,
mesmo se eu fizer isso sob a
descrição do "ato corajoso"
por si só, se eu não expressar
um traço contínuo do meu caráter
que me leva a fazer o mesmo em
outras circunstâncias
que exijam coragem... nenhum crédito.
E, na verdade, Aristóteles
impõe uma 4ª condição.
E essa 4ª condição é articulada
no parágrafo inicial do
Livro II, Capítulo 3.
E tem o seguinte teor:
"Devemos tomar como sinais
indicativos do caráter o prazer
ou a dor que acompanham os atos;
porque o homem que se abstém
de prazeres corporais
e se deleita nessa própria
abstenção é temperante,
enquanto o que se aborrece com
ela é intemperante;
e quem arrosta coisas terríveis e
sente prazer em fazê-lo,
ou, pelo menos, não sofre
com isso, é bravo,
enquanto o homem que sofre é covarde."
Então, vamos voltar à nossa lista.
Para uma ação contar como virtuosa,
na imagem de Aristóteles,
você tem de praticá-la sabendo
que é o ato virtuoso.
Você tem de praticá-la porque é
o ato virtuoso por si só.
Você tem de praticá-la como
expressão ou resultado
de um traço permanente do seu caráter.
E você tem de praticá-la com prazer.
Você tem de praticá-la de tal forma
que não sinta como se fosse uma
imposição agir assim.
A pessoa corajosa na
visão de Aristóteles
é a pessoa que, conscientemente,
pelo bem de ser corajosa,
regularmente, e com prazer, age
como a pessoa corajosa age.
Na próxima quinta, vamos
começar a analisar
uma teoria ética que desafia o 1 e o 2.
Vamos analisar uma teoria
ética: o consequencialismo.
Uma versão particular do
mesmo, o utilitarismo,
diz que o valor moral de um ato
não depende de forma
alguma do conhecimento
ou das intenções da pessoa
que executa o ato.
Os textos que lemos para
hoje consideram,
respectivamente, a 4ª e
3ª condições.
O texto de Julia Annas questiona:
o que significa satisfazer a 4ª
condição de Aristóteles?
O que isso significa?
Qual é a sensação de ser um
indivíduo para quem a prática
dos atos de acordo com a virtude é
algo executado com prazer?
E o outro texto para hoje –
o de John Doris –
põe em causa se ??a ideia de que
para o ato ser virtuoso
ele tem de vir de um estado
firme e imutável não
pressupõe algo defeituoso
sobre a psicologia humana.
Portanto, os 2 textos oferecem
uma compreensão cuidadosa do
que está acontecendo
no Livro II, Capítulo 4, do
Ética a Nicômaco.
Eu vou retornar a esses textos,
mas antes de fazer isso,
eu quero ver se todo mundo entendeu
esses 4 requisitos,
em que eles agregam a ideia inicial
que nos tornamos corajosos
praticando atos corajosos, justos
praticando atos justos,
temperante praticando atos temperantes.
E que todos entenderam como isso
saiu do texto aristotélico
que estamos analisando.
Então, alguma pergunta
antes de continuar?
Tudo bem, então o artigo
da Julia Annas,
que é uma estudiosa da filosofia
antiga, traz a seguinte questão:
como seria ser uma pessoa
boa aristotélica?
Ou seja, o que é isso às vezes
chamado de fenomenologia
(o que se sente por dentro) da
virtude aristotélica?
Aristóteles disse
que a pessoa corajosa é aquela
que age corajosamente
sem sentir aflição na coragem,
achando natural e prazeroso
agir como pessoa virtuosa.
A pergunta de Annas é: o que é
isso que se sente por dentro?
E a resposta dela é: o que
se sente por dentro
é o tipo de harmonia interna
que falamos em muitas das aulas
desta unidade do curso.
"Exercer a virtude é algo que
envolve uma harmonia
de sentimentos e
deliberações na pessoa
virtuosa,
ao invés de um sentimento de
inclinações superadas."
É estar num estado de harmonia interna.
Os compromissos
reflexivos, os instintos,
a percepção de mundo em torno de um,
os padrões de cuidado com
o meio ambiente...
tudo unido de tal forma
que nem sequer se contempla uma
possibilidade alternativa.
A pessoa corajosa, na
imagem aristotélica,
não está no campo de batalha e pensa:
"Uuh, deixa eu ver o que
faria a pessoa corajosa
e o que faria a covarde.
Oh, ser covarde é tão tentador,
mas eu acho melhor evitar".
A pessoa corajosa está no
campo de batalha e
– como a pessoa que moldou
uma lei normativa numa
lei descritiva –
sente como se não houvesse nada mais
a ser feito além da ação corajosa.
Na imagem aristotélica, a pessoa justa,
quando confrontada com a
possibilidade de dar a quantia
certa
ou a quantia errada de troco
numa transação,
não pensa nela mesma: "Será que se
eu tirar vantagem do cliente,
eu serei descoberto? Mmm, acho que não.
Bom, acho que farei a coisa certa".
A pessoa virtuosa, na
imagem aristotélica,
nem sequer contempla a
ação alternativa.
E, consequentemente,
não sente necessidade de superar
a tentação alternativa.
Não há um sentimento de resistir a um
impulso na direção contrária.
Há um sentimento de que o
mundo se apresenta
com o que é para ser feito e
o caminho é por aí.
Como quando você vai jantar na
casa do seu amigo...
quando fiz isso, não pensava em vocês:
"Que lindos castiçais de prata.
Eu deveria levá-los para casa ou
deveria deixá-los aqui?".
Portanto, para o virtuoso aristotélico
é esse sentimento no que diz
respeito a qualquer coisa o que podemos
pensar como um dilema moral.
Mas Aristóteles também tem um pouco
a dizer sobre como é estar
numa condição onde esses
sentimentos divergem,
onde eles puxam em sentidos diferentes.
E as passagens que leremos
de Aristóteles
para a próxima terça
abordam exatamente isso.
Como é ser alguém que tenha de se
esforçar para ser virtuoso?
Cujos instintos funcionam
em outro sentido?
Ele está na posição de
fazer essa pergunta
porque ele já nos disse no Livro II
como é estar neste estado
virtuoso e harmonioso.
A sugestão de Julia Annas é que
podemos articular essa ideia
num paradigma científico
contemporâneo se inspirando
numa ideia particular da psicologia
positiva, a ideia do fluxo.
Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi, um
psicólogo húngaro,
nos últimos 30 anos mais ou menos,
tem conversado com pessoas que se
destacam em algum domínio
para saber o que elas sentem
enquanto desempenham a atividade
que realizam tão bem e de forma
completamente engajada e absorvente.
Ele conversa com compositores,
alpinistas, bombeiros, músicos...
e pergunta como é a sensação
de estar num estado:
um estado atlético, musical, criativo,
de absorção na parentalidade eficaz;
não importa o que está sendo feito,
se é feito bem e com gosto.
Qual é a sensação de
estar nesse estado?
E ele afirma – como vocês devem ter
visto na palestra no TED –
que quando a nossa atenção
está deliberadamente
enfocada no que estamos fazendo,
a ação é experimentada sem esforço.
Num estado de completa absorção,
estamos atentos às nuances
sutis da experiência.
Você está jogando basquete
e as posições do aro, da bola, da
sua mão e dos outros jogadores
estão lá para você como uma
percepção única.
Você está absorvido num jogo de xadrez
e tem uma sensação da posição
das peças no tabuleiro.
Você está envolvido numa conversa
com alguém que você ama
ou que você cuida e todas as nuances
e todas as sutilezas da interação
são evidentes para você.
Agora, o que Annas percebe é que existem
2 características específicas
da experiência de fluxo que são
realmente fundamentais
para a antiga noção de
harmonia-da-alma da virtude.
A 1ª é que a atividade do fluxo,
a atividade em que você está
totalmente absorvida,
é experimentada com o que ela
chama de autotélico.
Na verdade, ela está utilizando a
terminologia usada por Csikszentmihalyi.
Auto significa "em si
mesmo"; e télico, "fim".
Designa algo que tem o seu
fim em si mesmo.
Não é um meio para um fim.
É algo que tem...
Uau! Eu lembrei de uma coisa de A
República de Platão,
das páginas iniciais, na nossa
primeira atribuição de leitura...
É algo que nós experimentamos
como tendo valor intrínseco.
É algo que, ao fazer,
não estávamos pensando
nisso só como um meio
para algum outro fim.
Estávamos pensando nisso como algo
que é agradável por si mesmo.
Um pintor que pinta os quadros pensando:
"Por quanto é que eu vou ser
capaz de vender isso?"...
no momento da pintura, não está
absorvido na pintura por si mesma.
Um atleta que pensa sobre o seu
desempenho apenas em termos
de quantos pontos ele ou a
equipe vai marcar
não estará totalmente
absorvido na atividade.
Acontece que, mesmo para as
coisas de valor instrumental,
a forma mais eficaz de
executá-las com excelência
é estar tão absorvido nelas
que as sentimos como tendo
valor intrínseco.
E isso nos dá uma nova visão
sobre a divisão das 3 vias
que vimos nas páginas de
abertura do Livro II
de A República de Platão, quando
foi dito que há coisas
que são instrumentalmente valiosas,
coisas que são intrinsecamente
valiosas e coisas que são ambas.
Isso nos dá uma forma de entender
como até mesmo para as coisas
que são apenas
instrumentalmente
valiosas,
podemos nos comprometer com
elas de tal forma
que as sentimos como tendo
valor intrínseco.
E isso é, naturalmente, tanto uma
virtude quanto um vício.
O produto mais famoso com valor
meramente instrumental
é o dinheiro.
As notas no seu bolso, ouso dizer,
não valem muito mais que uma
fração de centavo
como pedaços de papel.
Mas elas têm valor instrumental
dentro de um sistema
econômico de dar e receber.
Porém, mesmo dentro desse
sistema econômico,
elas só tem valor instrumental
porque o dinheiro por si
só não é útil.
O dinheiro é útil porque
nos permite comprar
outras coisas que são úteis por si só
– belos carros, bons alimentos,
tempo para gastar com os
amigos e familiares,
oportunidades de visitar
partes do mundo.
Tudo isso são coisas que
podemos comprar com dinheiro.
Mas o dinheiro em si possui apenas
utilidade instrumental.
No entanto, a mesma função
psicológica humana
que nos permite fazer algo
como um arremesso num jogo de basquete,
que tem naturalmente um
valor instrumental,
como se fosse de valor intrínseco
– que nos permite viver
a experiência,
que nos permite ter essa
experiência de fluxo –,
pode ser redistribuída ao ponto
de chegarmos a pensar
que quem morre com a maior
cifra na conta bancária
de alguma forma ganhou um jogo
cuja pontuação não era arbitrária.
Portanto, existe – como
muitas vezes é o caso –
um lado positivo e um lado negativo
sobre a psicologia humana:
o fato de que somos capazes de
experimentar coisas
que talvez não tenham valor
intrínseco como se elas tivessem.
E, na verdade, essa experiência é uma
das coisas mais poderosamente
envolventes que podemos fazer.
Exatamente porque, quando todas as
nossas energias estão dirigidas
para a atividade, nos perdemos nela.
Há um sentimento...
e Csikszentmihalyi descreve isso
nos últimos 5 minutos da palestra
que eu enviei para vocês.
Há este sentimento de
completa absorção,
um sentimento de
"não-autoconsciência", um sentimento
de ruptura
entre as fronteiras do eu e as
fronteiras do mundo.
Você se torna parte da cena
em que você está
experimentando o fluxo.
E, de fato, no momento em que
a autoconsciência
ressurge, o fluxo é interrompido.
Qualquer um de vocês que já
praticou um esporte
ou um instrumento musical, atuou numa
peça ou deu uma palestra,
sabe o perigo de sair da cena e ver
a si mesmo fazendo isso,
o quão perturbador pode
ser a experiência.
Portanto, Annas sugere que a ideia
de virtude de Aristóteles
é a ideia de que a virtude e a
atividade da virtude
devem ser sentidas como um fluxo.
Devem ser sentidas absorvedoras.
Devem ser sentidas não-reflexivas.
Devem ser sentidas... quando você
está no ato de ser corajoso,
justo, temperante,
magnânimo, magnífico
ou qualquer uma das outras
virtudes aristotélicas,
o que se experimenta nesse
momento é a sensação
de que você está fazendo algo sobre
o qual não existia escolha.
Essa é simplesmente a
maneira como o mundo é...
em que você sente que existe
o valor intrínseco
e onde você se sente totalmente
absorvido e inconsciente.
E Csikszentmihalyi segue em seu
trabalho mais sistemático
para explicar que a razão
pela qual isso ocorre
é porque há uma
correspondência profunda
entre o seu nível de habilidade e o
desafio que a atividade apresenta.
Quando somos confrontados com uma tarefa
que não é um desafio para nós
e à qual temos pouca habilidade,
experimentamos o que
Csikszentmihalyi chama de
apatia.
Se há algo que não é muito
difícil para mim,
mas eu não sou muito bom,
haverá pouca motivação
para responder a isso com engajamento.
Se o meu nível de habilidade é baixo e
a tarefa é um pouco difícil,
eu poderia me sentir aflito diante da
minha incapacidade de cumpri-la.
E se o meu nível de habilidade é baixo
e o nível de desafio é alto,
eu poderia sentir ansiedade.
Continuando, se o meu nível de
habilidade é moderado
e a atividade é de baixo desafio,
eu vou experimentar uma
sensação de tédio.
Eu não vou me ver envolvido nela.
Eu vou achar a situação chata.
Se o meu nível de habilidade é
médio e a atividade é
de grande desafio, eu poderia
me sentir estimulado.
Eu poderia me sentir curioso.
Eu poderia sentir um pouco de
motivação para agir dessa forma.
Mas os casos em que sentimos
mais emoção no mundo
são os casos em que temos as
estratégias de enfrentamento
que nos permitem agir
eficazmente como agentes.
Vocês devem se lembrar que,
quando lemos o material
de Jonathan Haidt – para a última
classe e a anterior –, ele descreveu
um experimento que foi feito no
andar de uma casa de repouso
onde os pacientes tinham a
responsabilidade de cuidar das
plantas
do andar ou então
alguém cuidava delas.
E o nível de felicidade
daqueles que estavam engajados
na atividade era muito maior.
Ser capaz de ser
uma força agente no mundo é,
para os seres humanos, uma das
principais fontes de felicidade.
E se pensarmos de novo no que
falamos algumas aulas atrás
sobre a importância do apego
seguro da 1ª infância,
uma forma de entender o
que o apego seguro
inclui é um sentimento de
protagonismo no mundo.
Se chorar faz com que o
seu cuidador venha
até você para satisfazer as
suas necessidades,
você se sentiu eficaz como um agente.
E assim, quando o nosso nível
de habilidade é alto,
mesmo que o nível de
desafio seja baixo,
nós executamos a atividade sentindo
um certo tipo de relaxamento.
Aqueles de vocês que jogam
"bubble pop games" no celular
e são bons,
já devem ter sentido isso.
Muitas vezes temos alto
nível de habilidade
numa atividade de baixo desafio
e isso permite nos sentir que
estamos relaxados.
Quando temos alto nível de
habilidade e um desafio médio,
temos essa emoção de controle.
A ideia aqui é de algo que
você está tentando fazer.
Você tem muito bom domínio dele
ele oferece esse
sentimento de eficácia.
E, finalmente, temos uma célula
não exposta nesta matriz.
E é a célula que nos questiona o que
ocorre quando temos um alto
nível de habilidade e uma
atividade desafiadora.
E vocês não vão se surpreender ao saber
que aqui é quando o fluxo cai.
Portanto, a sugestão de Annas, com
base em Csikszentmihalyi,
como uma forma de entender Aristóteles,
é que ser virtuoso por dentro é
estar totalmente absorvido
por uma atividade que, de certa forma,
é extremamente desafiadora.
Isso envolve escanear o mundo de tal
maneira que você reconhece
quais são as situações moralmente
exigentes e agir com habilidade,
naturalidade, sem esforço, feliz num
estado de harmonia, de uma
maneira que esteja de acordo com o
que o mundo exige de você.
E fazendo assim você é totalmente
absorvido numa atividade
que é sentida como tendo
valor intrínseco
e onde o sentimento de você mesmo
como um agente distinto
desaparece por causa da absorção.
Então este é o 1º artigo
que lemos para hoje.
Algo que diz: aqui está uma
demanda feita por Aristóteles,
aqui está um jeito de entender
essa demanda no vocabulário
de um trabalho contemporâneo
da psicologia social.
O 2º texto que lemos para hoje
trata exatamente do oposto.
John Doris, depois de uma série
de outros filósofos,
incluindo Gilbert Harman,
sugere que a psicologia
social contemporânea
mostra que é a circunstância,
em vez do caráter, a principal
determinante da ação.
O que determina a forma como
agimos numa situação,
de acordo com Doris, de acordo
com a psicologia social,
o que determina a nossa ação
não é algo estável em nosso caráter,
não é a condição 3 de
Aristóteles que isso seja um estado
que persiste ao tempo,
mas sim as características
incidentais da situação.
E, como resultado da psicologia
moral aristotélica,
em especial na sua 3ª condição,
isso exige um comprometimento com o
que os psicólogos sociais
chamam de erro fundamental
de atribuição.
Para explicar o erro
fundamental de atribuição,
vou apresentar a vocês um estudo
que serve como exemplo
de paradigma, mostrando as formas
em que a circunstância,
e não o caráter, aparece para
determinar o comportamento.
E vou apresentar este estudo
tanto porque ele é central
para esta literatura quanto
por nossa 2ª aula,
quando lemos um texto de um dos
seus autores, Batson.
E quando chegarmos à
seção de punição,
vamos ler um texto de outro
autor: John Darley.
Portanto, a parábola do Bom Samaritano
– quem foi criada na
tradição religiosa cristã –
é uma história contada por
Jesus no livro de Lucas,
quando ele é indagado
basicamente pela mesma questão
que propusemos a Platão e Aristóteles:
Como eu posso me comportar
da forma exigida pela moralidade?
E a história contada por
Jesus é a seguinte:
"Certo homem descia de
Jerusalém para Jericó
e veio a cair em mãos de
salteadores, os quais,
depois de tudo lhe roubarem e lhe
causarem muitos ferimentos,
retiraram-se, deixando-o semimorto.
Casualmente, descia um sacerdote
por aquele mesmo caminho.
E, vendo-o, passou de largo.
Semelhantemente, um levita
descia por aquele lugar e, vendo-o,
também passou de largo.
Certo samaritano, que
seguia o seu caminho,
passou-lhe perto e, vendo-o,
compadeceu-se dele.
E, chegando-se,
pensou-lhe os ferimentos,
aplicando-lhes óleo e vinho."
Aparentemente, isso é uma coisa
boa para fazer nas feridas."
E, colocando-o sobre o seu
próprio animal,
levou-o para uma
hospedaria e tratou dele."
E a história continua.
Ele dá dinheiro ao hospedeiro
para cuidar do homem.
E Jesus diz à pessoa que
pediu uma história:
"Isso é algo que você
também deve fazer".
Assim, a história do Bom
Samaritano é uma história que,
se você pensar bem, deveria levar
ao reconhecimento da virtude
de ajudar um estranho com necessidade.
Isso deveria evidenciar que,
entre as exigências morais
que o mundo coloca para você,
se alguém está ferido
ao longo do caminho e você está
numa posição de ajudá-lo,
então estaria de acordo com as
exigências da moralidade parar
e despejar azeite e vinho
nas suas feridas
– ou qualquer que seja a analogia
contemporânea para isso.
Portanto, o estudo realizado por
Darley e Batson foi o seguinte:
Eles selecionaram um grupo de alunos
de uma escola de teologia
em Princeton.Vocês podem vê-los ali,
com as suas roupas de
jovens seminaristas.
E pediram que alguns deles
preparassem um sermão
sobre a parábola do Bom Samaritano.
Eles são alunos de teologia,
presumivelmente pessoas
que estão comprometidas com o
desenvolvimento do caráter moral.
E foi pedido que eles
preparassem um sermão
sobre algo que faz muito, muito
sentido para eles... ou seja,
se você passar por alguém que
está precisando de sua ajuda,
você deve parar e ajudá-lo.
E o que Batson e Darley fizeram foi
dizer a alguns seminaristas
que havia pouco tempo para chegar
ao outro lado do campus,
onde eles precisavam dar uma palestra.
E a outros, eles não disseram nada
disso. E uns seminaristas
foram encarregados da
história do Bom Samaritano
e outros receberam a demanda de
preparar outra história.
Agora, vocês podem estar pensando que
se fosse verdade a hipótese
de que o comportamento
determina o caráter,
esses seminaristas que
prepararam uma apresentação
sobre o Bom Samaritano estariam
particularmente propensos
a reconhecer as
necessidades morais
inerentes
quando se deparassem com alguém ferido.
E a questão se eles estavam
atrasados ou não para a palestra
não teria qualquer influência.
Darley e Batson decidiram testar isso.
O que eles fizeram foi induzir
a ida dos seminaristas ao auditório.
E, no caminho, havia alguém
deitado na calçada
precisando de ajuda.
O que foi preditivo para saber se
os seminaristas pararam
para ajudar o homem
não foi se eles tinham preparado uma
história sobre o Bom Samaritano...
Foi se eles estavam com pressa
para chegar à palestra.
E aqueles que estavam, muitas vezes,
não só não ajudaram o homem
como passaram por cima do seu corpo e
correram para o auditório.
Todos nós já experimentamos
isso. Se eu estou com pressa
para pegar os meus filhos e
tenho de encostar
porque vem uma ambulância, eu me
sinto incrivelmente contrariada.
Por quê? Porque eu penso "Oh,
essa pessoa na ambulância,
ela merece morrer, porque eu tenho
de pegar os meus filhos..."?
Não. É porque quando a nossa
atenção está dirigida
para um objetivo externo, é muito
difícil para nós estarmos atento
às características morais
de uma situação.
E isso ocorre um monte de vezes
quando estamos tentando decidir
o que levou alguém a agir de
uma determinada maneira;
temos uma tendência a
sobrevalorizar o caráter
(características disposicionais) e
subvalorizar a situação
(características da circunstância).
Poderíamos pensar, por exemplo
– este é o 1º caso no
artigo de Doris –,
que ajudar ou não a recolher
os papéis de alguém,
quando eles caem no chão, depende de
uma característica de caráter.
Você é uma pessoa prestativa ou não?
Mas parece que você pode manipular
se as pessoas estarão dispostas
a ajudar simplesmente
deixando elas encontrarem 1 centavo
numa cabine telefônica.
(Se você não sabe o que é uma
cabine telefônica, há um filme
chamado The Matrix e eles têm
cabines telefônicas nele.)
Encontrar ou não 1 centavo
na cabine telefônica
é o que determina se elas ajudam.
No estudo do Bom Samaritano, não
é se eles estão pensando
em ajudar... é se eles
estão com pressa.
Nos experimentos de Milgram, não
é se – em geral –
eles se comportam de uma forma ou de
outra; é se eles se encontram
numa condição em que é feita
uma exigência para eles.
Nos casos de "sorte moral" no Vietnã,
não é que esses jovens que
estiveram na guerra
e se viram numa
circunstância tinham um
caráter
que os levou a agir dessa forma,
segundo esta teoria; é que eles se
viram nesta circunstância.
Portanto, para John Doris, a teoria
aristotélica não pode s certa.
Ela pressupõe uma imagem errada
da psicologia humana.
Já são 11h20.
No início da próxima aula
eu vou abordar 2 resultados da
psicologia social que desafiam,
em certos aspectos, a afirmação que
Doris faz contra Aristóteles,
e depois vamos continuar com a nossa
discussão sobre Aristóteles...
o que fazer em casos de
fraqueza da vontade
e que estratégias estão
disponíveis se não satisfazemos
as 4 condições aristotélicas.